[Music]
since the action does take place the
lack of Fitness between purpose and
reality is not taken seriously at all on
the other hand action itself does seem
to be taken seriously in point of fact
however the actual deed is only a deed
of the individual consciousness and
therefore itself only something
individual and the result contingent but
the purpose of reason as the universal
all-embracing purpose is nothing less
than the whole world
a final purpose going far beyond the
content of this individual deed and
therefore to be placed altogether beyond
anything actually done because the
universal best ought to be carried out
nothing good is done in fact however the
nullity of what is actually done in the
reality of the whole purpose alone which
are not postulated these two are in
every respect again displaced the moral
action is not something contingent and
restricted for it has as its essence
pure duty this constitutes the sole
entire purpose and thus the deed no
matter in which other one other way its
content is limited is quite
actualization of that purpose the
accomplishment of the entire absolute
purpose or again if reality is taken to
be nature which has its own laws and
stands in contrast of your duty so that
Duty cannot realize its law within
nature then since it is Duty is such
that essentially matters what we are in
fact concerned with is not the
fulfilment of pure Duty which is the
whole purpose for the fulfillment would
really have as its purpose not pure duty
but its antithesis reality but there is
again a shift from the position that it
is not reality with which we are
concerned for according to the notion of
moral action pure duties essentially an
active consciousness thus there's
certainly a lot to be action absolute
Duty ought to be expressed in the whole
of nature and moral law to become
natural law
paragraph 619 is fairly long and there's
really two main things going on with it
if there's essentially two different
discussions that Hegel is engaging in so
it could have been broken down into two
shorter paragraphs but for some reason
Hegel puts them together and we might
think about how these are in fact
connected as we reach the end of the
commentary on this particular paragraph
619 he begins by bringing up this
general idea that we've already broached
of what's being translated here as a
lack of fitness one on msyn heights
we'll come back to that in just a moment
between what between purpose vac and
reality
vir click' now what is the purpose the
purpose is that of satisfying moral duty
of making morality actual as we've seen
and so we have a discordance there's
another way of translating this blue
anonymous and height in in opposition to
a harmony we have a lack of mapping on
to each other a literally in commence
durability or lack of common measure
between the two of them there's a lack
of a mediating third term or is their
consciousness is going to be that
mediating third term as we're going to
see but that's not apparent at this
point so Hegel actually begins this
paragraph by saying because action hond
lung does take place we've talked about
that just in the previous paragraph this
lack of fitness this lack of connection
this not mapping on to each other
properly this discord ins this
contradiction between purpose and
reality is not taken seriously at all
that doesn't mean that this doesn't
exist or that it's going to be
you know forgotten on the side and never
come back in as we're gonna see it's
gonna raise its head very quickly right
but it means that we can put it aside
for the moment and just focus on the
action so he says action itself does
seem to be taken seriously and we saw in
the previous paragraph maybe this is the
way out of this conundrum the way out of
the fundamental contradiction the nest
of contradictions or antinomies or
antitheses whatever you want to call it
at the heart of the moral consciousness
may be action instead of being something
that merely follows from thought or
practical reasoning may be action
reveals to us not just results but an
orientation that we could then follow as
Hegel putting forth something like this
well he he seemed to suggest that to us
as a way out of this predicament but now
he's going to focus on another key
aspect of action that we all too often
forget about when we talk about action
when we talk about anything that the
human being the self-consciousness is
engaged in all too often we forget that
we are still not just talking about some
abstraction or some character in as you
know Hegel's phenomenology has been
called a bildungsroman that is a sort of
coming of age or a developmental novel
of something that we call spirit
how does spirit in fact act within the
world it doesn't do so by you know
top-down fashion saying here's what's
going to happen now I need to find some
husks that I can inhabit and move around
no it engages actual human beings in
their specific reality in their humanity
and the depths of their personality and
here he's expressing this in terms of
individual consciousness so he says in
point of fact the actual deed the actual
doing the action whatever it happens to
be that's attempting to satisfy moral
duty and bring it about in the world the
actual deed is only a deed of the
individual consciousness now notice the
next thing that he says it could be that
my deed is an action of me but in some
way it's representative or its
determinative of so many others right so
think about these performative actions
carried out you know like the signing of
the Declaration of Independence or
something that winds up being video
recorded and standing in for thousands
of other people saying or doing the same
sort of thing think for example of the
recent video of the woman on the
Scandinavian airline who stood up and
refused to sit down until the Afghan
refugee was not going to be deported
right and and filmed herself doing this
it's a completely individual act and and
this is a great representative of that
because she was for a few moments
entirely alone the plane turns hostile
against her somebody tries to steal her
cell phone and the stewardess
fortunately gives it back showing some
human solidarity that she is also
showing to another human being this is a
good example of moral action right and
she can stand in for other people who
are engaged in similar acts of
resistance to how state power is being
used against unfortunate and vulnerable
people who you know are fleeing
countries that have been essentially
wrecked not only by their own internal
dynamics but by other countries coming
in and wrecking them further now what
does Hegel say about this sort of thing
he says the actual deed is indeed of the
individual consciousness therefore
itself only something individual and the
result is contingent so in a sense even
when we do these these sorts of big
gestures stand in for humanity writ
large kind of actions it is that of the
individual you can look at again to use
this example you can look at this woman
video recording herself explaining what
it is that she's doing talking about the
time that's passing and whether the
pilot is going to do this or that or the
ground crew is going to do this or that
or the authorities are going to do this
for that carrying on a conversation
through I think it was Facebook
live-streaming you can look at that and
you can say well it's dramatic because
we don't know what's going to happen
let's say the person does get taken off
the plane and now it seems like they're
gonna get asylum everything is great but
you know somebody could get off the
plane and and kick them and they die or
they fall down the stairs and break
their neck or the cops are there waiting
to throw them into a cell and send them
on another plane or and we can go on and
on and on so every single action that we
engage in attempting to do our moral
duty is radically contingent there's no
guarantee that the purpose the the end
that's Veck and reality are going to
measure up through each other are going
to conform to each other they are
contingent so what does this mean for us
here Hegel makes a contrast between the
purpose of reason the Zek there you know
fair knowing right as the universal
all-embracing purpose there is a larger
purpose that we feel like we can align
ourselves with but we can never really
measure up to and participate in the way
that we would like so he says this
Universal all-embracing purpose is
nothing less than the whole world
that's an interesting thought
what does he mean that this universal
purpose is the whole world the world as
it currently is as screwed up as we find
it as irrational or only partly rational
as so much of its processes and
individual persons and cultures and
dynamics seem to show itself no the
purpose is that of transforming the
world making it a fully rational a fully
humane a humidified you could say that
has made completely human world a world
that has been transformed and here you
can see this nature lurking in the
background nature which we are a part of
is something that has its own laws and
yet is to be transformed transformed by
what by moral purpose it is to be made
good rational beautiful noble whatever
description that you want of it there
that is the purpose of reason of
fairness it's not simply to know the
cosmos it is to transform the cosmos to
make it how it should be and then you
might say where the hell do you get an
idea about that through reason by using
reason to understand our very nature and
our possibilities this was the process
the the project and the process of the
Enlightenment but it didn't get carried
through all the way and we saw that it
again ends up in detours like that of
absolute freedom and the terror so he
goes on and he says this is a final
purpose going far beyond the content of
this individual deed that's an important
point now you might say well you know
you put together enough individual deeds
and that's how you actually fulfill this
purpose of reason it's going to be this
kind of approximative ameliorative
building reforming process that will
eventually culminate in something like a
better world that we all
ream of or hope for or at least pine for
even if we don't want to admit it but
Hegel here wants to emphasize the
contrast he says that this final purpose
is placed altogether beyond anything
actually done and here I think all of
you have probably heard the expression
as an imperative
don't let the best be the enemy of the
good if you haven't heard that what it
means is don't allow a certain sort of
perfectionism
that looks to the best and uses that as
its standard to detract from the good
the actual good the veer cleek the real
good that is being done or that is in
front of you or that is available there
is a tendency within us towards this
kind of perfectionism towards this
denigration of the real good and in this
case it's the real good that is
accomplished in moral action which is
indeed contingent but is aimed at some
sort of moral purpose that of satisfying
duty and insofar as it accomplishes it
even insofar as that aims at it and
strives for it and makes the right
choice it is good but it's not the best
so it doesn't satisfy the purpose of
reason itself so look at the next thing
he says because the universal best ought
to be carried out nothing good is done
now is Hegel in fact saying nothing good
as done no this is the deception that
consciousness at this point in time is
carrying out upon itself and we as the
phenomenologist we're looking in and
saying that is a screwed up perspective
to hold this person or this this
consciousness is indeed allowing the
best to become the enemy of the good so
he says in fact the nullity of what is
actually done and the reality of the
whole purpose alone which are now past
these two are in every respect again he
tells us displaced where did we find
this displacement in the previous
paragraph right so what does this mean
for us now he says that the moral action
becomes not something contingent and
restricted because it has as its essence
pure duty this constitutes the sole
entire purpose and the deed no matter
what in what no matter in what other way
its content is limited becomes qua
actualization of that higher best
purpose becomes the accomplishment of
the entire absolute purpose so in some
way we leave behind the particularity
the contingency the specificity of the
thing that we do and we look to the fact
that we are engaged in a moral say with
a capital L in engagement with the world
of actuality and we are in fact making
it actual in some way now that leads us
into the second discussion which is
going to introduce a new problematic
what if morality actually won what if in
its struggle with nature morality was
able to transform the world what would
be the case then and we saw this talked
about in the previous section he would
become a nullity so let's follow that
line of reasoning out he says if reality
is taken to be nature so here on this
side we're looking at the vehicle a kite
the actuality as nature the whole world
that we know with its own laws some of
which are physical laws you know having
to do with bodies some of which have to
do with our own psychological States
generalizations that we can bring about
ways in which our motivations produce
certain results either in line with or
contrary to duty
he says if nature which has its own laws
stands in contrast to pure duty now
notice there
your duty morality itself not
necessarily individual duties because I
could you know satisfy certain of my
duties my duty to take care of my
children for example could be because I
see in them little replications of
myself and therefore my narcissism leads
me to do the best by them so that I can
continue in existence long after I have
actually shuffled off this mortal coil
right from a moral perspective that's
not a particularly good act that's not
satisfying pure Duty if I take care of
my children it should not be so that I
can you know reduplicate myself and live
on forever it should be a recognition of
them as other human beings as vulnerable
as those who are to be taken care of
because that is incumbent upon me and
you know these are different options for
us so not every fulfilment of Duty is
indeed a fulfillment of pure duty many
of them can be prompted by nature and
its laws so he goes on and he says if
Duty cannot realize its law within
nature so this is a question right
how does Duty realize it's a lot with
the nature by acting by doing things
within the world of nature by imposing
or injecting moral consciousness within
it so he says then since it is duty as
such that essentially matters what we
are in fact concerned with is not the
fulfillment of pure Duty which is the
whole purpose the fulfillment of pure
Duty is transformation of the entire
world that would be transformation of
the totality of nature that would be
making the world anew and reconstructing
it entirely along the lines of morality
or of pure Duty is that a conceivable
outcome he says what we are concerned
with is not the fulfillment of pure Duty
which is the whole purpose for the
fulfillment would really have as its
purpose
not pure duty but its antithesis reality
and we're going to see in the paragraph
to come that there is a sort of paradox
here the more that you are able to make
this ideal world that is presumed in the
individual action that the individual
action never measures up to and yet at
the same time remains oriented by this
better or best world so long as you're
trying to make nature conform to that
there's some sort of struggle there
there remains when we start we're going
to leave aside the lack of fitness right
but it's been there the whole time
this incommensurability this not quite
mapping onto each other this let's just
call it what it is conflict a
dialectical conflict within
consciousness itself about what is going
to matter more nature what we're
confronted with in our experience what
we find as we engage in observing reason
as we find as we go through the
consciousness section as we go through
the self consciousness section the
dialectic of of recognition is is in
some respect part of that nature is it
not and yet there's something better
something more distinctively human that
we can try to bring about now if we do
bring it about and you might even say
the closer we get to bringing it about
this paradox raises its head we'll come
back to that in a moment but assume we
could totally bring it about transform
nature the entire cosmos into a
completely moral universe would there be
any room left for morality for
individual actions that are oriented
towards the purpose of doing the moral
thing would you be moral if the whole
world was set up in such a way that you
automatically were directed towards
doing the right thing if you had what
can't called a holy will a will that
just simply recognized what the good is
and automatically chose to do that that
had never to struggle against its
desires and inclinations and everybody
else around you is that way too so you
would never have anybody vexing you
because they're acting like a jerk being
motivated in the wrong way themselves
would there be some scope for morality I
mean you could say there's no scope for
this this best part right because you've
already accomplished it it's no longer a
project or a goal or a Zack and ideal
but there would there be room even for
this individual action only insofar as
we're still screwed up if you imagine
that moral universe in which everybody
was a good guy except for you you were
the odd duck right you are the one who
who sees things differently and you
behave in ways they don't like and so
you know you get thrown in jail or sent
to reconditioning camps or maybe they
just sit down with you and talk real
nice and try to you know show you the
irrationality of your behavior
well I suppose then you could change it
in so doing and becoming like the rest
of them you could become a good guy but
would you really be good in the sense
that we typically talk about this is the
paradox of morality and actuality and
attempting to impose a harmony on it so
we come back here then he says there is
again a shift from the position that
it's not reality with which we're
concerned not veer clea kite why he says
according to the notion the concept the
beginning of moral action pure Duty is
essentially an active consciousness it
is not a passive consciousness it's not
a merely implicit consciousness it has
to know what it's doing I mean we can
see this in looking at classic virtue
ethics this is one of the problem
addicts that comes up within virtue
ethics in certain misinterpretations of
it think about Aristotle for example
he says that what what defines a person
as virtuous is having certain habits
certain hexes we can also translate that
as dispositions they have built up
something within themselves through
habituation through making it part of
the fabric of their character right and
they do the right thing in the right way
at the right time etc etc etc it's a
mean position there's one other part of
this that's really important that's
particularly pertinent to this question
of activity they know what they're doing
they do it consciously if we want to use
Hegel's way of thinking about it
Aristotle doesn't have this this sense
of consciousness in the language
available to him at the time he just
talks about knowing that they're doing
that thing knowing that they're being
just knowing that they're being tolerant
and temperate in respect to anger
knowing that they are being generous
knowing that they are being properly
ambitious knowing that they are
exercising good humor all of these
virtues that he brings up they know on
some level that they're doing it doesn't
mean they have to be like a hyper
conscious person all the time totally
thinking about what am i doing right now
but they do have to have on some level
consciousness of that it cannot be
automatic it cannot be merely
instinctual it cannot be like a robot or
like a animal who has been trained or
else it's not moral and when you see
certain interpretations of virtue ethics
they almost sound as if the goal is to
use our brains to eventually cut out the
need for thinking whatsoever so we'll
just automatically do the right thing
sort of like a sprinkler you know
shooting up the water because goodness
is flowing through it from the hose and
it just casts it out like that in a
mechanical fashion that is the opposite
virtue is supposed to make us more human
duty is supposed to be a recognition of
what is incumbent upon us as human
beings as moral beings so Hegel goes on
to bring the section to a close and he
says there ought to be action absolute
duty ought to be expressed in the whole
of nature moral law ought to become
natural law not just be recognized as
natural law in the way that natural law
theory thinks nor simply conceptualized
the way that can't you know does in his
for example first formulation of the
categorical imperative implicitly in the
second but then again explicitly in the
third no we are supposed to transform
the cosmos and make its one that is
moral so that we would in fact be
naturally moral beings now is this going
to work we've got the ideal set up
before us are there any big problems
with it we've already talked about a few
and then the paragraphs to come Hegel is
going to show us the contradiction at
the very heart of this project
you